Hey guys,
I just filmed the same video two times in a row.
Sometimes things just go wrong.
The video distorted.
I checked out the settings.
I fixed it.
I filmed it again and then for some reason it
distorted again and my computer auto-upgraded
itself and installed some updates
and then the audio settings were
at 100 percent on the microphone.
And everything distorted again.
And I'm down here now to get some coffee
and I just wanted to share this with you.
It's like a pastor who would stand there and
preach his whole sermon and then go again and
then he has to do it again a third time and it
gets tiring so you know everything here at home
here doesn't happen just smoothly.
There are challenges.
But, I'm going through these challenges
with God that gives me strength.
Wanted to share that with some of you
who might need this message today.
Love you guys.
Bye.